what's up man what you been up to oh I
just all you just what just uh so that
you just casually just walk on through
like everything's cool huh I haven't
seen you in 15 years
won't you sit the [ __ ] now where they at
huh where are they at I don't know you
talk you don't all done even know what
uh you don't know what that okay uh I've
kept your secret for 15 years didn't
tell anybody
nope [ __ ] you Santa [ __ ] me [ __ ] [ __ ] me
is that how I'm talking Santa Claus
that's right man where is it there where
all my gifts you get watch ah damn get
you go kid we go
Merry Christmas look at this that was he
some kind of [ __ ] joke huh a lump of
coal that's right you've been a naughty
boy this year not open up you got proof
March 12 2009 you robbed a Baby Gap that
Alexandra Wallace no you ruined his life
she dropped out of school now she
turning tricks for money she walk that's
funny I don't think that you should be
judging me on that one June 24 2010 you
punched a deaf mute I thought he was
throwing up gang signs that's a
different story you know what
how are you gonna be judges whose daddy
or not because I don't say why your
ghetto ass gets to do that how the [ __ ]
am i Cairo you break into millions of
homes every year that's not ghetto to
give gifts to millions of children
around the world yeah you steal the milk
and cookies too huh huh much like a
kajillion years old
well yourself some pedophile so so so
long pedophile huh he sees you when
you're sleeping he knows when you're
awake he knows if you've been bad or
good I didn't write this song David you
don't never told anybody you were black
right which doesn't even make sense in
the first place why would you even keep
that a secret which you ashamed let me
taste them
back then if a black man came down your
chimney with a bag over his back
you wouldn't think he's there to give
you gifts okay well why don't you
explain this one to me then huh why is
it that you're always going through
anybody's chimneys huh
tracking your freakin ashes all over the
damn floor huh your filthy ass McNasty
call me dirty one more time and I swear
to god I'll pick up this big-ass batter
go upside your head look I'm saying you
go through chimneys but you can't go
through a keyhole or something with your
little magical powder dust huh I don't
have time for this David it's Christmas
I got [ __ ] to do do all you still walk
up in the middle of a conversation huh
is that what you're going do that crazy
Oh God what the [ __ ] are you doing
use the front door I'm not going outside
dressed head-to-toe in all red they're
doing the goddamn blood
you
they shall grow
can I stay here with you it's going on
YouTube that was a little quick little
Christmas kid idea for you guys and you
see the gobbles back from Mexico that is
where it is that that's how we got this
tan mess up gobbles back from Mexico
spoke up I mean I wait sighs language um
thank you very much merry Christmas to
all yours and yours and yours and yours
sometimes keep on going and anyways amen
I got yourself let's go baby Oh Merry
Christmas oh you actually put something
in our prop okay oh okay yeah that's
what the box is heavy remember you
promised to go where you promised you
look any problems you did you put it on
no put it on top put it off put this
[ __ ] on put it on okay dog I'll just see
you put it on pornography [ __ ] no not
me anyone we all ate Merry Christmas
everybody
beaver makeup what arms
this is hella Mexican Oh shucks Oh
useful good of you to see you guys next
year that's all ways to do it him here
once he said Nance cat daddy cat daddy
yeah daddy can't okay I'm in here